Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David Pakman Show.
I am Jesse Dallimore sitting in for David while
he is away. Let's let's talk about a common
refrain, a common turn of phrase that I use,
and that is a dignity free performance. I am
baffled by Republicans, especially election
deniers out there, who are shameless in their
efforts and in shameless just in general about
their lies and their predictions and everything
else that just never comes true. And Mike Pillow,
as David likes to call him, the Mypillow goof.
Mike Lindell He is maybe chief among them.
In the Dignity Free performance category.
He was on. He was on Jimmy Kimmel.
And it was a remarkable like, what is this guy
doing? It's sometimes when you watch him, it's
so perplexing that he's I think this guy is a true
believer. And then sometimes he does other things.
I'm just I don't understand it. So let's let's
let's put our heads together here and watch this.
Jimmy Kimmel stuffed him into a fake
prop claw machine and made him do his
appearance on the show from the machine.
And he went along with it. Watch this.
Speaker 2: All the colorful, unhinged characters
have come to prominence in the political era of
Donald Trump. Our next guest is probably the most
enthusiastic to help him overcome his debilitating
fear of machines. We have installed him inside
a claw machine for his interview tonight. And
joining us now from the corner of Donkey Kong
and Cubert, the Mypillow guy, Mike Lindell.
Speaker 3: Jimmy Crumble. Is that you? It's me.
Speaker 2: Well, my first question, Mike, is why
do you think people don't take you seriously?
Speaker 3: Well, I. You know, I want to tell
you this, Jimmy. When we were kids and we
question these carnival games, whether they
were rigged or not. Yeah, right. But when we
spoke up back then, we didn't get sued, did we?
Speaker 2: Oh, that's right. Hey, Mike, get
rid of that kid. Will you give him a toy or
something like that?
Speaker 3: You know,
you got a winner. It's a big game. Hey.
Speaker 2: Mike, I know that you're
distrustful of machines now that you're
inside one. Do you feel differently?
Speaker 3: They're all the same thing. They're
so their computers can be rigged out there.
Absolutely. In elections, You know that.
Speaker 2: Did you ask Donald Trump whether
you should do this or not? Do you
run this sort of thing by him?
Speaker 3: No, I didn't, Jimmy. I did this all on
my own. I wanted to be on your show. You you know,
you kept telling me to come on. But you you know,
I seen the monologue there. You said it's because
to put me in here because I was was a vaccinated.
You tricked me. You did it to be funny, huh?
Speaker 2: No, I didn't. No, I didn't want you
in there because you weren't vaccinated. I don't
know. To be honest, I don't even remember why I.
Speaker 3: Decided you should be in the show.
Speaker 2: You said about your show it seemed
like a good idea when it happened. I have to say,
I was very surprised when you said you would do
it. But, you know, I put it out there and so you
said yes. So I you know, I'm honoring that.
Speaker 3: Commitment that I made on the
air. That's great.
Speaker 1:
I mean. Oof! Comes to mind. Cringe comes to
mind. Embarrassing, humiliating. All of these
terms. What is he doing? He's not bolstering the
case that he's correct. He's he's he's creating
a situation where any credibility there was
none anyway that he may have had is just.
Like dust in the wind. Bizarre, to be sure